gang it's win by two not here it's not
hey they letting your instructor's in
the gym now
well I just noticed you're not getting
enough legs under the shot are you
dehydrated 100 bucks you can't make more
shots let's just do 300. it's not my
dad's money
[Music]
they ain't never gonna get a reparation
that way bro so I prefer venmo or Zell
but you seem like a cash app guy so
you think it's slick huh it's showing up
the course dressed like a dumbass acting
like you can't who you assumed I
couldn't who because I'm white which is
incredibly outdated I assumed you
couldn't hoop because you were dressed
like a white girl at Whole Foods
it's really hard to plan for the future
when we're always worried about money
because you're out here living in a
fantasy my 30-day detox program you want
a free sample no I ain't drinking no
boo-boo juice babe it's almost the first
I'm gonna go tomorrow I forgot why don't
you just go now we're gonna be fine hey
don't worry mommy don't worry about me
every Hooper I know is entering that big
ass tournament with a winner get 500
000. I just need somebody who can play
so I can make some money
you're joking right 500 000 for one day
I hope yeah yeah yeah
hustle a few games together to get the
money for the entry fee I'll find some
marks those short shorts look incredible
throw them off their game yeah the only
fast and we'll clean up you're gonna
wear that trash bag you're gonna wear
that fake ass Richard Simmons outfit
bro I bet you all got more in common
than me release for me
release for me
don't spend any money until we can cover
the feet I should be saying that to you
well I'm good with money so am I so am I
me too me too where where are you bro
[__] it what just wanted to see if you
had superhuman hearing because of you
because
they're gonna kill him in the parking
lot I'm out of here he got a
flamethrower flamethrower what is this
Mad Max
you talking your ass later today good
work thank you you could talk way more
trash out there you have so much
material I can't even touch
like what
never mind oh
tell us what a Love Goes
[Music]